I currently work at the European Court
of Auditors in Luxembourg in the area of
communication I work for the council as
their online communication officer I
work from the communication unit of
director-general resources and security
of the European Commission
I basically advise the director-general
for communication in online strategy so
it means how to adapt all our
communication products and our services
to the new digital environment I deal
mainly with the internal newspaper mmm
that is Commission and directs I write
articles also work on the supplement
that contains more Human Resources news
we are dealing with press we're dealing
with external internal communication
were trying to advertise the products
that our auditors are producing I
studied political science and
international relations and I also had
an interest in anthropology but when I
started working actually I started
working in the communications field I
said the communication in Italy I've
studied languages I've studied
literature studies sociology
communication was part of that I start
work working as a journalist more or
less based in Brussels but also I travel
around Europe I have started ndu as a
translator in the Slovenian language
section of European Court of Auditors
and I have later on moved to
communication to director of a
presidency where I still work
the degree of urgency that is inherent
for communication whenever I come to
work whatever plans I have made before
there is always something that just
comes in between that cuts cuts in and
that needs to be dealt with with a
degree of urgency my job position is
really interesting because you can make
contact with a lot of different
colleagues from different services you
talk about their job their work
experience also about their experience
outside outside the job in fact in the
newspaper we give a lot of space about
personal experience like in volunteering
traveling or whatever kind of
interesting initiative there are two
really exciting parts of my job the
first one is that I work Cross DG's or I
work across the board of the activities
of the institution so I really have a
good understanding of actually what the
institution is providing and doing and
the second part is that because I'm
working on processes strategies and
systems I I have the impression I hope
it's true but I have the impression that
I can really contribute to change most
of the work is done in English but my
director is French so we interact a lot
in French as well and I'm working on my
Spanish so that's really good and I
would also like to take some non EU
language to expand the scope of where I
can find actually relevant information
for EU institutions the European
institutions encourage multilingualism
which means that people working for the
European institutions are encouraged to
take part in language trainings and
myself I have taken part in several of
them I've started French from scratch
when I came to Luxembourg I had no
knowledge of it before and later on I
started learning Italian and I'm now
finishing that class and I'm thinking of
refreshing my German and Dutch the
language component is so prominent
because of the official languages being
23 whereas in most intergovernmental
organization
you went for example only has six so
that creates a big complexity in terms
of information flows and since I work in
communication
information for us it's an additional
constraint that we always need to factor
in best way to keep one skills
up-to-date is to attend trainings I
think one should never skip on that so
in my current job I do a lot of
communication trainings trainings on
public administration on functioning and
international environment and with
different languages of course I just
came out of a training that was over the
last three days which was the
introduction basically to working for
the EU and I was extremely helpful
because we there were people from
different institutions and it was very
interesting to hear how other newcomers
were experiencing their entry into the
EU environment and in general I think
that trainings really really help in
getting a good grasp of how the EU
institutions work they had the training
in internal communication and that of
course is the the core business of my
unit and I'm going to have a quite soon
our training on video making
I actually have a liking for the adviser
position which I'd like to explore more
and one of the option would be to join
the cabin a of a commissioner which is
kind of the political office of a
commissioner or it could be also to
continue in a more strategic role at
institutional level or also to join a
delegation abroad for example I think
that in these times it's very difficult
to foresee one's future but I'm very
happy and I consider myself lucky to be
working for the institutions and for the
European Court of Auditors
in specific and the European
institutions of a very interesting
career path and if you're if you set
your goals you can also set your vision
to achieve them go for it and if at
first you don't succeed in the in one of
the absurd competitions do not give up
it's a very rewarding career path that
is waiting for you there are a lot of
opportunities for continued learning and
personal development and I'm certainly
very happy and I consider myself lucky
that I've been working in the European
institution so far
you